this has been the scene for months every
day hundreds of refugees line up outside
Berlin state health and social services
agency or lagay so as it's known by its
German acronym hoping to get registered
by authorities who are clearly
overwhelmed Cara haidar who's from Iraq
spent the night out here he's come to
secure the regular pocket money allotted
to refugees and to make sure he has a
place to stay next month every four
weeks he has to go through the same
routine lucky sir give me one month in
time or on the hotel why not give me six
months ok why I I come here every one
month why give me six months give me one
year three month to month ok Clara had
our managed to cross the Mediterranean
in an inflatable raft then he traveled
through the Balkans and arrived in
Berlin four months ago now his greatest
obstacle to survival is chaotic
bureaucracy I'm waiting 20 day no money
no eating sleeping the in the street and
every day I come here I am I am sleep
here outside volunteers like crystianna
Beckman do their best to help the
refugees any way they can they give
advice and reassurance to people who are
powerless to improve their situation in
the face of authorities unable to cope
with the numbers of new arrivals thirsty
jets guns cut off on 15 it clearly
states here that on the fifteenth of
December he should go to room 321 at ten
o'clock without a waiting ticket he came
but he wasn't led in this place is
riddled with incompetent and
unwillingness to help nothing's been
prepared for the very situation people
have been warning about for years
vermont ID on Dauphine give is not as a
speci invert a lack of willingness is
something John on by Tom an opposition
politician has also observed despite
staff changes she says hardly anything
of the agency has improved no one from
the gay so is willing to speak on
politic marketing i'm booked as he
snitchin the officials responsible for
this mess give the impression that they
don't want to come to grips with the
situation even though it's a manageable
one if the will were there the problems
could be solved Berlin has plenty of
possibilities to hire more staff to
register these people and a state would
save a lot of money if it did that gauge
pod and venison mentioned is to be
inverted if the refugees were registered
more promptly they could be resettled
throughout Germany sooner instead for
days on end they wait here for their
turn for a new appointment and yet
another long line